One question I would like to ask you
that you have been 14 years of
experience. So, what is your next goal?
Like after 5 years or 10 years, how do
you see yourself? And how do you see as
a DevOps industry? How it will grow in
next 5 years in next 10 years? Yeah. So,
I'll answer this question in general,
right? Not not specific to DevOps,
right? When I started working, I started
like in the introduction I mentioned
that for the initial 6 to 7 years I was
into software development. When I So,
when I was into like 4 to 5 years, I was
like fascinated like with designations.
Guys, I used to feel like managers,
directors. And I thought that I'll also
become a manager or a director one day.
But right now, I'm leading a team of 30
technical people, right? But I I'm still
doing 3 to 4 hours of hands-on work.
Yeah.
>> I will consider myself successful over
the next 5 to 7 years if I'm able to
maintain that 5 to 7 4 to 5 hours of
hands-on job. Okay? hands-on work. So, I
consider people should not worry too
much about the designation. With the
advent of AI,
I think every single person needs to
stay hands-on or they will get absolute,
okay? So, that is going to happen for
sure. You will see a smaller number of
teams, right? So, initially with big
companies, you used to see thousands and
thousands of engineers, but it is slowly
changing, okay? So, there are startups
with like 5 to 10 engineers and they are
doing 30 million dollars of business,
okay?
>> Yes.
So, that is going to happen over the
next 5 years, I believe. A person should
have at least basic information or basic
knowledge of all the aspects. And with
the help of AI, they can learn other
stuff as well, right? So, if you ask me,
full stack is the need of the hour. So,
a person needs to understand front end,
back end, databases, and cloud and
DevOps. So, even it is okay if they are
not expert in a particular area, but
they need to understand all the stuff.
And with wipe coding tools and other new
tools that coming up in the market, they
can write software. They can create
enterprise grade solutions. It is not
there yet, but maybe in the couple of
years it can reach that state. Having
said that,
it is going to give you problems. It is
going to fail in production. It is going
It It Maybe it will not work. But you
should be having the capability to make
changes to that AI written code. Okay,
that is what I said. There are a lot of
people who do a lot of wipe coding. So,
at the MVP stage, they are like very
successful. But when it hits production,
they start to face scaling issues. They
start to face security issues. That is
where the main challenge or your
experience comes into picture. Okay. So,
the people with no programming
experience or no DevOps experience or no
software engineering experience will
fail over there.
And we need to make make sure that at
least we should be able to make changes
or update the code that AI has written.